hello freak [ __ ] hey we got two super
important things to talk about one this
is John Jones think people keep saying
that John Jones because of this drug
test he did a a blood test and he did
tested negative the blood test taken
test he passed the blood test he'll do
urine test but here's the thing the
blood test doesn't test for that stuff
correct I'm getting it straight from
nowitzki oh you talked to her you talked
the gold slug test because they can talk
about it because John has gone public
with correct the blood test does not
test for this t-ball stuff whatever the
FIR and all but the urine test does
correct so they have two urine samples
and then the results of the urine sample
B will be out soon and then we'll know
game changer did you here Chael Sonnen
he said with toronto ball it's so
old-school
like if you're gonna do that you
basically whoever's giving it to them
has their black belt in peds so a few
test spots for a Toronto ball you're
probably stat they missed the good stuff
cuz you're stacking out with a bunch of
other [ __ ] slightly just can take some
old-school training ball and not taking
anything else this is so crazy how weird
is it so crazy because I know I did not
if if this is true hmm I did not think
that he was a cheater I thought that he
was a guy who was [ __ ] off and
partying and got busted with some Freak
[ __ ] that's in some dick pills because
they tested those an ability I never
bought that narrative here's two options
right there's two options when it comes
to those dick pills those dick pills did
have these steroids in them but do you
know that why are you taking them
because if you just take them and you're
getting steroids - you're getting
steroids and your dick it's not enough
where it's gonna be a performance and
like it's such a small micro dose of
testosterone where the [ __ ] is in those
things think it's a clomiphene yeah
whatever it is but I just I I think John
has some smart people around him they
painted that narrative like oh yeah he's
a party or was taking dick pills that
makes sense why you would test pause for
this stuff when I feel like the recipe
pond the no were like
not really well like this monster be
taking IQ dick people down if take
people down in my day before to never
happen if I can turn towards dick pills
you know I'm late I like to party as
much as the next set not Jonjo there's
levels to this party game got John Jones
style well yeah obviously at kokanee
system - he does like to party for
really get that and then that's what you
know Brian Redman called it because
people that do coke that dick doesn't
work that good so then they stack it
well with with vitamins like really and
he was telling me about cuz Brian loves
those goddamn gas station dick pills but
he's like they're totally inconsistent
he's like you'll get one you get these
raging hard-on as you get another one
you feel like a homicidal maniac like
you you get crazy aggressive you know
what's in my life I'm saying but I yeah
I just I never bought that narrative
with John I didn't well now we know you
know the the urine test from a is
positive because that's what tested for
that substance in the urine the blood
test is irrelevant they were attempting
see but in and then people that don't
get that you see oh but he passed the
blood test right you guys full of shits
like no no the urine is the big one here
I saw it that zone doctor was posting
that on doctor Hightower I guess this is
chiropractor
doesn't count yeah he was posting out on
Instagram free John Jones and I was like
well this is not like smartest
chiropractor talking about the wrong
substance the wrong test rather don't
get it I think what's the goddamn it is
the [ __ ] do with the weed finally
turning down you know that's it yeah my
car was covered in ash this morning yeah
yeah it's out there bro it's scary yeah
but with John you gotta listen what
chill had a good narrative on I think I
don't marry our with their Hani he's
just saying that's such an old-school
drug like to be associated with that
does pause for that and he's like I you
know he said the same thing because I
know a few things about pd's for God's
sake he does yeah and so he was saying
that old-school drug they're missing the
good [ __ ] like he got away with a lot of
other stuff if you if that's in your
system you just don't you know I'm
saying it's like if you want a car
you're not gonna just get a [ __ ] 64
Ferrari Daytona yeah
I would write some other [ __ ] self a
civic yeah exactly
oh yeah with one bad tire yeah gamer's
levels to this for god sakes what do you
think happened I think you just got
caught yeah well I and I'm sure you
could talk to the novitskiy when I say
go and snitch that's a complimentary
term I don't dislike the guy think he's
cleaning up the sport anyways yes it's
clean it's going straight there tell
your boy the constants just relax a
little bit no he's not
can't do it Luiz cláudio there he goes
Luiz cláudio apparently is a master of
that [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] Lee showed the
big man choking [ __ ] is out he showed a
lot of people that choking they're like
what the [ __ ] just nasty huh yeah I
guess it's just somehow another the way
he's holding it he's going into your
neck into your throat as he's choking
you with it's just you know it's like
people just develop the finest like
application of one technique like they
just get it down whether that's their
[ __ ] do it Ralph will tap out Barnett
with that yes how you know that shit's
legit
Barnett's as legit as it gets grandpa
way yeah you surprised him with that
[ __ ] insane and you see when he got him
like Josh Wilson he was like what [ __ ]
yeah just like god damn what are you
doing it was nasty like he wasn't
getting out of that and a lot of ways
those kind of like old-school chokes
like that's a lot of [ __ ] Josh Barnett
sinned too right hell yeah that's tough
break your neck off I like Josh yeah how
about I had a Goldberg um on firing the
kid you know Goldberg the wrestler and
he was he's real he's like best friends
with Brock and I said do you think
Brock's gonna come back and he goes he
was going to till John piss hot oh my
said you breaking my heart Goldberg oh
my god oh my god right don't let that
[ __ ] up your Saturday you thought the
fires coming in [ __ ] you SATA data [ __ ]
your Saturday oh I can't do this right
p.m. on Saturday I literally just went
and I'd like to go back to get out come
on get the [ __ ] out what in the [ __ ] is
wrong crazies that he was going to we're
gonna see that monster again what is
wrong with the world Jesus Christ
whoever that meathead is that gave that
[ __ ] to John John's got to be on suicide
watch right now sitting there with the
[ __ ] one of those shakes you know it
was probably I [ __ ] in Warren bro I
warned my swear we should get a team
together like Navy SEAL Team six and
just still [ __ ] him up basically a
tainted batch you know I gave him gave
him the right stuff I took the same [ __ ]
I passed yeah [ __ ] I almost said Dirk
Nowitzki maybe they didn't know about
the maybe they're testing over and over
again with the blood test see I heard it
the new test oh the urine test is nash
tickle and snitch about it bro you got a
direct line to him who I will he's gonna
come on the podcast again after Jon we
get the thing about John well I mean if
it times out that way if not we'll do it
before but I'm gonna have monsoon yeah
kind of delay it though to that so we
get the real [ __ ] him for you I'm
saying yeah probably a good idea it's so
depressing to me because it felt like
John returning the way he did like
that's like a superstar victory he
handled himself with class and dignity
after it was over I mean everything
about it was amazing and then to go from
that to piss and hot you're like oh no I
was at Universal when I found out Jamie
texted me you texted me and I thought
you're [ __ ] with me I thought it was I
think that's all he's [ __ ] Harry
Potter ride [ __ ] your day up life's
pretty good Harry Potter ride was fun I
thought yeah I thought it's fake news
[ __ ] man super fakeness super depressing
you